las vegas will soon be home to a new  memorial remembering those killed in the  holocaust today crews breaking ground on  the holocaust memorial plaza it is being  built outside of king david memorial  chapel near robindale and eastern  organizers say it will honor the 6  million people killed in the holocaust  it will allow  visitors and locals alike to be able to  come out here and to be able to learn  about the holocaust at the same time be  able to reflect on people that have that  within their family or other families  that have passed away  the memorial will also include  educational elements to make sure future  generations truly understand the horrors  of the holocaust it should be fully  completed come april